bienvenue et merci vous êtes venus pour
nous parler votre nouveau spectacle
oui c'est un spectacle que j'ai pris un
peu le temps d'écrire après un petit
moment et c'est vrai que pour moi
j'avais j'avais envie de remonter sur
scène surtout on va dire de nos jours
parce que c'est une période un peu
délicate est vrai que là la notion
d'humoristes au delà de fait rire je
pense que c'est aussi de passer des
messages donc c'est un peu ce que
j'essayais de faire sur sur ce nouveau
spectacle
finalement vous n'êtes pas si con
politique
nous allons suivre gérard le point qui
est avec nous dans le 14e arrondissement
pour des rebondissements nous allons
directement dans le sud de la france
[Musique]
allez hop on taffe signature on est
parti pour deux belles années ensemble
exactement moi je te remercie écoute
cheikh photo énorme fête magique magic
énorme tu auras viger
âgés pata pata
[Musique]
thomas
q
coupez complet pour toi vous êtes ph
qu'as tu fait la personne n'y croit
depuis ce matin mais on ressent rien
qu'est ce que fait on perd sur 9 km par
la bastille à froid mais oui abbas en
réalité où mon vieux
ça fait deux heures que je m'en fous de
deux heures chagny ils ont tourné trois
ans j'en ai marre de tourner avec un
rigolo comme ça c'est pas possible qu
merde bosses tu es venu comme à coeur
comme mec tu es nul ne donne rien tu
fais chier mais une grosse merde
pauvre merde voilà merde allez potter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah que je serai là
[Musique]
thomas t'as pas vu la demande
bon pour moi sans blague
[ __ ] vous avez pas restituer la dame
femme de tomber donc tu attends kaslik
oui
[Musique]
alors tu l'as auquel a procédé à l ai
dit non me force pas monter là parce que
si je mens tu sais comment ça va se
passer et robben sommer la dégager 500
poulets frits dégueulasse ouais c'est
pas des chômeurs c'est ma conscience un
jamais été maire d'accous ni bon
attendez qu'il peut alors y ait un sens
on peut être alors j'ai grandis tu te
parle pas de ce qu'on a pas les gars
minable un chat jean paul ii blonde qui
sert à rien inquiet la poste va être une
grosse équipe qui a un gros coup algérie
[Musique]